so you're the american government in the
early 60s you're right in the middle of
the vietnam war and honestly things are
not looking that great you went into the
war thinking that you would dominate
vietnam without a second thoughts that
this war would be a total breeze you
have bigger stockpiles of better weapons
allies nearby and millions of american
soldiers ready to fight the good fight
in the name of their country but you're
running into a big problem the terrain
the vietnam war was mainly fought in the
harsh heavy jungle of northern vietnam
and your soldiers weren't used to this
type of environment at all it was hard
to see through all the thick foliage and
made it impossible to get armored
vehicles through the area and it
basically eliminated the possibility
that the air force could swoop in and
help you were fighting at half of your
capacity because of the jungle while the
vietnamese on the other hand were
absolutely thriving in the jungle
battlefield the vietnamese soldiers knew
the jungle and how to use it to their
advantage it provided them with a
million hiding spots and cover it made
it easy to set up traps and capture
american soldiers and in general it was
giving the vietnamese a potentially war
winning advantage you simply weren't
gonna stand by for that i mean vietnam
beating the united states no way you can
never let that happen so you decided
it's time to pull a strategy from the
british playbook during the malayan
emergency a little trick called
herbicidal warfare the plan was to use a
special chemical to destroy the jungle
it killed two birds for one stone first
it destroyed the vietnamese soldiers
natural cover leaving them with nowhere
to hide and totally defenseless and
second it demolished their food source
leaving them hungry weak and desperate
the plan would leave the enemy like
sitting ducks and strip them of any
advantage they once had and even better
you knew the perfect chemical that would
make every plant in sight wither within
a few days agent orange
one of the rainbow herbicides agent
orange was given his name for the orange
strip around the big metal containers it
came in it was a 50 50 mixture of two
different herbicides and it was
unbelievably powerful agent orange would
melt the leaves the day after it was
frayed it would seep into the ground and
make it impossible to grow anything and
best of all it was oil salutable so it
couldn't be washed away even during the
rainy season agent orange was
accomplishing everything you wanted in
the short term but it will also come
with a lot of unintended consequences
it's more than three decades since the
end of the vietnam war the guns are long
silent but the conflict continues to
inflict horrifying damage on millions of
vietnamese they are the innocent victims
of toxic chemicals used by u.s forces to
clear the jungles the way i remember
hearing the story is you know we lived
in this
tiny little town of a couple thousand
people in new hampshire
and this small town surgeon and
surgical team opened him opened him up
and said that he was found him to be
full of cancer
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime of my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
all you have to do is follow me on
instagram at jaketran and you're
automatically entered watch out for fake
accounts i will never message you asking
for money or to invest and this is the
horrific story of agent orange
agent orange was used as a vicious tool
to get america what they wanted no
matter the cost while we all want things
like money power success there are a lot
more ethical ways to get them like
learning new skills and making yourself
a more well-rounded person and you can
learn a lot of these skills on
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
courses that allow you to discover and
explore your passions after all the
people making the most money are the
ones with the best skills and skillshare
can help you learn all those skills
right now no matter what topics you're
interested in you will find it on
skillshare there are just so many unique
and interesting courses like starting a
successful side hustle by youtuber ali
abdul or productivity for artists or
personal branding crafting your social
media presence i would personally start
off by taking real productivity how to
build habits that last by youtuber and
author thomas frank it teaches you
everything you need to know about
setting and reaching realistic goals so
you can do anything you put your mind to
there are a ton of experts teaching on
skillshare right now skillshare is
always putting out new useful courses
and you'll never be distracted by ads or
interruptions during your class plus the
entire course catalog is now available
with subtitles in spanish french
portuguese and german the first 1 000
people to use the link skillshare.com
jake or my code jake tran will get a one
month free trial of skillshare that
skillshare.com has jake with the link
below to start learning on skillshare
today
thanks to skillshare for sponsoring this
video
more than 80 000 tons of these chemicals
[Music]
it's november 30th 1961 president john f
kennedy is about to make a decision that
will change the course of history as he
signs his name on the dotted line to set
up operation ranch hand and approves the
use of herbicides in northern vietnam
it was the beginning of a nightmare for
millions after only a couple of months
the spraying begins the air force would
use three to five planes in an organized
formation the planes were equipped with
tanks in the fuselage and spraying
nozzles on the wing
on every mission each plane sprayed down
an area that was 260 feet wide and 10
miles long less than a decade later the
american air force had completed nearly
6 000 missions and sprayed over 5
million gallons that's enough chemicals
to fill more than seven olympic swimming
pools
they sprayed us with a liquid at the
time we were hiding in a tunnel
underground
but even so after they sprayed us
breathing was difficult
and our eyes watered as if we had pepper
in them we told each other they are
spraying
chemicals
by the end of the war american soldiers
would end up spraying vietnam and other
nearby countries with 20 million gallons
of herbicides
the americans on the ground were told to
spray down the area around u.s military
bases with trucks and hand sprayers
which meant a lot of us soldiers were
coming in direct contact with agent
orange all the time when they asked if
it was safe they were told by the
american government of course will we
put you in harm's way
some soldiers were even straight up lied
to and told the chemical drums were
other substances
one of the things we did was
we unloaded
barrels of uh
what they said was insecticide to kill
the mosquitoes here and um so that
people wouldn't get malaria
but it turned out to be agent orange a
dioxin so
for me it's a very um
a very emotional issue to try to make up
for that heart
make a mental note of that for later the
american soldiers were instructed to
cover the roads rivers canals rice
paddies and farmland with ancient orange
everything as far as the eye could see
should be dripping in the super potent
herbicide and this caused a few
unintended casualties like accidentally
spraying south vietnam cambodia and laos
even though they weren't involved in the
war but that didn't matter because the
fact was the plan was working agent
orange was killing off the forest like a
dream
some military personnel even used to
joke that only you can prevent a forest
a twist on smokey the bear
only you can prevent wildfires
but there was a reason that agent orange
was working so well because it's one of
the most toxic substances ever created
not just for plants but for every living
creature including us humans the thing
that makes agent orange so toxic is a
byproduct that's created during the
herbicide manufacturing process a kind
of dioxin that's called tcdd
dioxins are the dangerous stuff is put
out into the environment when trash is
burned or people smoke cigarettes it's
one of the most well-known carcinogens
and it lasts for years in the soil which
is pretty bad by itself but tcdd is the
most dangerous out of all the 419
dioxins in the world and it wouldn't
take long for everyone to find out just
how destructive the tcdd in agent orange
was
so you're a vietnamese soldier that's
just come in direct contact with agent
orange what's going to happen to you
well to start off let's say you were
only exposed to the dioxin agent orange
for a short time your skin will darken
you'll probably develop a really painful
skin disease called chloracne and you'll
have some problems with your liver later
in life you'll be at higher risk for
type 2 diabetes immune system
dysfunction nerve disorders muscular
dysfunction hormone
but it's unlikely that you'll get off
with just a couple of inconvenient
health issues for short-term exposure
because once the dioxin seeps into the
environment it's in everything for at
least the next
after asian orange is sprayed everyone
is practically guaranteed long-term
exposure and the effects of that are way
worse
lauren curry i'm 41 years old my dad was
george cameron appel jr went by cameron
and he
was diagnosed with cancer when he was 34
and died just after his 35th birthday in
1978.
the way i remember hearing the story is
you know we lived in this
tiny little town of a couple thousand
people in new hampshire
and this small town surgeon and
surgical team opened him opened him up
and said that he was found him to be
full of cancer lung cancer leukemia
hodgkin's disease multiple myeloma
prostate cancer and 12 other
life-threatening diseases are all
recognized by the american veterans
association as having a strong
association with agent orange exposure
aka if you have any of these diseases
and you were exposed to agent orange at
some point in your life that's probably
what caused it about 300 000 veterans
have died from ancient orange exposure
since the vietnam war nearly five times
as many as the 58 000 who died in combat
and around 3 million vietnamese people
have suffered health problems from agent
orange so far it's disturbing to think
of all the american and vietnamese
soldiers who thought the war was finally
finished only to get sick or die after
the fact but agent orange's reign of
terror doesn't end with the veterans
the vietnam war came to an end in 1975
after two decades of brutal battle
everyone tried to go on with their lives
as normal and put the pain of the war
behind them but it wouldn't be that
simple not with agent orange in the mix
once the next generation was born people
started realizing that we had a big
problem there were way more children
than usual being born with major birth
defects and disabilities they just
happened to be the children who were
born in areas where agent orange was
sprayed and the children of vietnam vets
who had come in contact with agent
orange
my life is so miserable
i really cannot imagine how my future
will be like
even though the dioxin in agent orange
only lasted a few years out in nature it
could have a half-life of up to 20 years
in the human body which meant a lot of
people were having babies when they
still had dioxin present in their system
developing babies are even more
sensitive to dioxin than adults and the
results were devastating
but for children like these da nang
school substantial help anytime soon is
unlikely in march the us supreme court
said it would not hear an appeal against
the manufacturers agent orange exposure
has been found to increase the rate of
stillbirths and it increases the chances
that a child would be born with spina
bifidia cleft lip congenital heart
disease neural tube defects and more
many of the children who inherited
health conditions from their parents
agent orange exposure end up in the
full-time care of a medical facility
what do you think has caused
dips problems
there are still babies born today who
are inheriting birth defects and
debilitating health conditions from
their great grandparents
she says 60 of them you know are
connected to agent orange then the harsh
reality is they are war victims and war
victims they're paying for a war that
happened over half a century ago and the
sad thing is
most of us have forgotten about it and
the toughest part of all this to swallow
is that so many people have already
suffered people who weren't even born
until 50 years after the vietnam war had
already ended and no matter what we do
now there's no changing their reality
one of the things that's super
challenging about an agent orange
connection is to have been
so kind of personally wronged by a
choice my government made and at the
same time
to
strive to be a good citizen
of that government
since agent orange was sprayed half a
million children in vietnam have been
born with serious birth defects
[Music]
for decades the united states tried to
brush the whole thing under the rug the
government really didn't want to admit
that they poisoned not only millions of
vietnamese people but also their own u.s
soldiers it was an embarrassment but
once people caught wind of the agent
orange atrocities they started demanding
that the veterans and children who were
affected by agent orange received
reparations four years after the vietnam
war ended 2.4 million american veterans
that were exposed to agent orange filed
a class action
after going back and forth for a few
years the bit wig chemical companies
that created agent orange finally agreed
to pay out 180 million dollars in
reparations to veterans of their kids if
they had already died it was a small
victory
then in 1991 president george h.w bush
signed the asian orange act the act
finally recognized a list of chronic
illnesses as being directly connected to
agent orange exposure and aim to
research it further after it was passed
us veterans who were part of the vietnam
war and suffered from an eligible
condition could receive compensation
it took 14 years of veterans fighting
before the agent orange act was passed
but what about vietnam well the u.s
wasn't nearly as in a rush to help them
but they managed to get around to it
kind of
they've donated a few million dollars
here and there
in recent years the u.s has agreed to
help clean up the most dangerous sites
of operation ranch hand at the danang
and bienhua air bases the project has
actually managed to bring america and
vietnam closer together and in 2019 the
united states agency for international
development agreed to give an additional
65 million dollars in aid over the next
five years to vietnamese people with
disabilities in areas sprayed with agent
orange it's a huge step in the right
direction and 65 million dollars sounds
like a lot but we're talking about
taking care of three generations of
people who still need a lot of help and
there's still a lot of work to be done
[Music]
the agent orange situation is pretty
messed up it destroyed the lands and
lives of the vietnamese people it
poisoned american soldiers and ruined
children's health for the next three
generations and what do you know it the
chemical just happened to be created by
one of the biggest and arguably most
evil corporations around monsanto which
is also known as the company that owns
the world's food supply
asian orange is only the tip of the
monsanto iceberg there is way more to
learn about monsanto and its business
practices that's why we've compiled all
of it into a single feature-length
documentary uncovering every dirty
detail but the thing is the video is a
little too spicy for my main channel
it's practically begging to get
demonetized or worse even sued that's
why we decided to release it as a
private documentary for our channel
members and so far it's a hit all you
have to do to see our monsanto
documentary right now and all the other
docs that are just too controversial for
the public is hit the join button below
after you sign up you'll get full access
to the monsanto documentary plus others
like the bin laden papers mk-ultra
efforty epstein and way way more to come
in the future
these exclusive documentaries hold some
of the darkest craziest secrets about
how the world works
it's the type of stuff they should be
teaching you in school but aren't and
right now you can get all of this for
just five dollars a month and what's
great is that if you join and you don't
think it's worth it just email me and
i'll personally refund you the money for
the last month you paid pause the video
and click that join button below right
now
[Music]
what's up guys hope you guys enjoyed the
video and if you're new here this is one
of the biggest channels on youtube for
documentaries on money power and crime
so if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button below if you want a
chance to win a thousand dollars you can
follow me on instagram at jtran but
that's going to wrap it up for this
video thank you so much for watching
stay dangerous out there and i will see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
you